take one I'm making this film because I
saw myself in your story
iris felt like I didn't fit in with my
family my parents ran this very
controlling house I ran away a lot
skateboarding is more of a family than
my fame how did you get disciplined
I mean well they call it child abuse now
life might be moving too fast we have to
fully grow up and it's gonna suck when
you're a kid you just do you just act
and then somewhere along the line
everyone loses that I knew you had some
huge weight on you
skateboarding meant more to you it was
kind of a life or death thing I remember
hearing that scream him coming from your
room and it was like really really
unnerving one of the last things I said
to my dad was that I hate you you can't
just have a child and abandon them life
doesn't work like that still wanting a
girl like me I just want to hide just
want to run away
that's what the drinking is about maybe
you're right maybe I'm gonna just move
on I wish you could I wish then I could
go over I could seriously be on the
verge of having a mental breakdown but
as long as I'm able to go skate I'm
completely fine
[Music]